BARBARA IMPERIALI: So what
we're going to do today
is we're going to finish
up a bit of transcription,
and then I'm going
to talk largely
about transcription control.
Because it's tremendously
important that we actually
not just know how to
transcribe, but we
know how it's controlled,
and how ultimately
the appropriate messenger RNA
is sent out for a translation
into proteins.
So transcription control is
a very important component.
So let me just start
with this first.
So these are typical
of questions.
And they look like, gosh, I
don't have enough information
to answer this question.
And it's basically about what's
known as the transcription
bubble, which is the portion of
the double-stranded DNA, where
transcription is occurring.
And so a transiently,
the double-stranded DNA
is opened up for the
RNA polymerase, which
remember has inbuilt
helicase activity to start
transcribing the gene.
So let's just say we have
the information we might give
you is that
transcription starts here
at this point on the
double-stranded DNA.
And what we want you
to know is that you
have all the information you
need to know which of the two
strands is copied.
Have you had a chance
to think about that?
Does anyone want to give
me a good answer to that?
Yes, here.
AUDIENCE: The
bottom [INAUDIBLE]..
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because
it's [INAUDIBLE]..
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Right.
So that reading things
3 prime to 5 prime,
and making things
5 prime to 3 prime,
is all you need to know
to answer this question.
So you would
straightaway know, OK,
we're going to start
somewhere here,
but we're actually
going to start
on the lower strand,
because that's the one 3
prime to 5 prime.
And we're going to
make the new transcript
in the appropriate direction,
and know what it's going to be.
So you can only read the
bottom strand in this case.
But watch out,
because you might be
reading the top strand in the
appropriate direction as well.
But what we've told you already
is where the start site is.
So you're going to
know that information.
If we'd put, for example, that
the start site was over here,
you might have different
answers to this question.
So the only singular piece
of information you need
is that you read 3 to
5, and you make 5 to 3.
Then you can also
fill in the bases
to know what the transcribed
sequence looks like.
And I always recommend when
you're filling in bases,
you just write 5
prime to 3 prime.
So you really are following
properly which is being read,
and the direction
it's being read.
And so if you were asked what
the new messenger RNA sequence
would be, you'd get it right.
And here I just
have a few questions
that will help highlight
the differences
between the transcription
process and the replication
process.
So can you guys just
read each of these,
and see whether
they look like rules
that apply to
transcription, or they're
things that are not true
about transcription.
So just give you one second
to think about that, who?
OK, who would like
to give me an answer?
Someone over in this
part of the room,
I haven't heard as much-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Makes a complete
copy of one strata.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: DNA.
OK, so the correct answer
is that we only transcribe
about 1.5% of the genomic DNA.
We're not transcribing
the whole thing.
We're only transcribing the bits
that we need to make proteins.
So the correct answer
is C, because we
don't make a copy of the
whole of genomic DNA.
But these are all right.
We have a different
set of nucleotides,
or rather a difference in one
of the nucleotide triphosphate
building blocks.
Remember that RNA polymerase
does not require a primer.
That was a complication when
we looked at replication,
because we had to paste
in primers, made often
by the primase, RNA primase.
All RNA polymerase is much
cleverer than DNA polymerase,
because it has the
polymerase activity.
It has the helicase activity.
There isn't needed
a topoisomerase,
because we're only
opening a little bit
of the double-stranded to copy.
I'll show you a
movie in a second.
And it also has a 3
prime exonuclease,
which means that RNA is able to
do its own proofreading, just
like the DNA polymerase.
So the error rate is
similar to the error
rate with the
exonuclease activity for.
DNA so that's about 1 in 10
to the 5 to 10 to the sixth.
Now I'm going to
talk in a minute.
There's not the same
cadre of repair enzymes
that we have for DNA.
And that's a curious thing,
until you start thinking
about what the reality is.
So let me try to lead
you to my thinking.
So with genomic
DNA, that's the copy
of the DNA that's in the
nucleus that has to stay good.
So if there's any mistakes,
we need them cleaned up.
Because otherwise
when we replicate
a set of all of the
double-stranded DNA,
there will be an error in the
progeny, the daughter cells.
For transcribing RNA,
an error rate of about 1
in 10 to the 5 to 1 in
10 to a 6, is just fine.
That piece of RNA ends up,
after a few of the processing
steps that I'll describe to
you, ends up leaving the nucleus
to be made into proteins.
And it's not such a bad thing
if you have a little bit
more error in that RNA.
Why is that?
Over here, or up there actually.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It has a
shorter life, so it's not
going to mess up everything
for the rest of its life.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Right, so
if you have a bit of an error,
maybe you make a new protein,
but it's not full length,
or the protein you make
isn't perfect; it's OK.
Because there'll be other
transcripts that are correct,
and then after you've
done making the protein,
then you're just
going to destroy
that RNA, because it has a
transient lifetime because
of the structure of the
RNA, and the nucleases that
chew up the RNA.
So this is an acceptable
error rate for RNA polymerase.
Remember, it's not an
acceptable error rate
to have in your genome.
OK, it's just too big.
Any questions about that?
Does that all make sense?
OK.
All right, so now
we want to talk
about transcription control.
But before I do that, I do
want to very quickly show you
something, because I feel
like it really caps off
the transcription part.
And I'm going to
show you only about
a minute of this,
because once again, I
love the sound effects here.
And I can't turn
down the volume.
This is one of those animations
showing transcription.
And it basically shows on
the double-stranded DNA,
lot of things accumulating to
make a decision with respect
to starting.
But now, the whole
complex, the RNA polymerase
is just screeching through the
DNA, making that messenger RNA.
And you're only unraveling
just a little bit of DNA
around that
transcription bubble.
So you wouldn't need
topoisomerase in this case.
You're only copying
one of the two strands.
We saw how to identify which.
And thus, the new RNA
strand is basically
falling out of the complex.
You can see [INAUDIBLE]
it's moving a lot.
So that gives you
a feel for things.
When I hear that
music, I'm just sort of
waiting for the whole
thing to crash somewhere.
But who would know, right?
All right.
So at the beginning
of that animation
a few things were
highlighted, where
there's the double-stranded DNA,
and a collection of entities
starts clustering around
where the reading is
going to take place.
So this thin, black strand
is the double-stranded DNA.
So some of the entities
accumulate quite close
to the start site.
There is a section of
DNA known as a TATA box
that we spoke about, at the
very end of the last lecture.
But there are a number
of transcription factors
that are quite important.
But then you might also,
if you go back and look
at that animation, there
are sections of DNA
that are at quite a distance
that also help really regulate
and promote transcription.
So many factors regulate where
the transcription occurs.
First of all, is there
a promoter site right
near where we need to start?
That causes a fair
amount of collecting
of complex components.
But then there may be
other things at a distance.
So the promoter region
might be located quite
near the transcription
start site,
but then there
are also enhancers
that can be located at
quite a big distance
away from the start site
that also play a role.
Why do we need
this much control?
Because we don't
need to be making
the RNA for every protein
all at the same time.
Certain times in cell
cycle you'll see,
I only need to make one
protein or a different protein.
So we need all of this control
to decide when transcription
occurs, when do we need
to make the messenger
RNA to make our favorite new
protein that needs to be made.
And you'll learn a lot in
signal transduction and cell
cycle, where we
really show you how
a lot of the housekeeping
genes are all fine.
The proteins are all there.
But at a certain
stage, we need to make
more of a particular protein.
And that's when the
transcription control
comes into play.
And you'll commonly
hear about things
called transcription factors.
And those may be the
proteins, for example,
that regulate that
transcription should start.
In other cases, there
may be times when
transcription is turned down.
So we have things that activate.
So we start transcription,
we make that happen,
or others that repress.
So they turn down transcription.
So it's all about when
you need to start,
which is controlled
by external factors
acting on the
double-stranded DNA
to send the transcription
complex, making the new entity.
All right, does that make sense?
We can't have a dysregulated
system, or if we do,
then we have problems
with, for example,
proliferation of cells.
All right, so what
I want to talk about
are the key things that
regulate transcription,
and the key things that we do to
the messenger that's been made.
So what you're seeing
here on this slide
is just where we
are in the process.
We've seen replication.
We're now at the
transcription step.
But there are many steps
to go in eukaryotes
before that transcript
can leave the nucleus.
All right?
And I want you to
remember the difference
between eukaryotic
and prokaryotic cells.
This was just a picture
we saw very early on.
Prokaryotic cells,
like bacteria,
do not have a nucleus.
They have an area
called a nucleoid,
but they don't have a discrete
membrane encased organelle,
where the processes of
replication and transcription
occur.
In contrast, in
eukaryotes, there
is a discrete area of
the cell, the nucleus,
that includes all the
machinery for replication
and transcription.
And it also includes
the machinery
that takes a pre-messenger
RNA into a mature messenger
RNA that can leave the nucleus.
If you send that
pre-messenger out there,
it's going to have a lot
of stuff wrong with it.
It's not going to
be ready to face
the outside of the nucleus.
It's going to be
readily degraded.
It's not going to have
the full information.
So I want to talk to you
about the processes that
are put in place
for this conversion
from the pre-messenger RNA
to the messenger RNA, which
we don't have to think
about in prokaryotes,
the small organisms
without organelles.
All right, so, and
this is the foundation
of transcriptional control.
All right.
So, we've talked about
promoters and enhancers.
Those happen early.
That's all about making
the pre-messenger RNA.
But now we have to discuss
some aspects that are also
critical for making the initial
pre-messenger RNA, and that's
chromatin remodelers,
or chromatin remodeling.
Because in order to
transcribe anything,
there's a lot of ground to
cover with respect to unwrapping
the chromatin, the chromosomes.
Because they're all
packed up in such a way
that you can't possibly do
any transcription there,
because they're too
tightly packed in order
to be accessible for the
transcription machinery
to tackle it.
So I show you parts of
that machinery up here.
These are the nucleosomes
that make up chromatin,
which makes up the chromosomes.
And in order for you to even
be able to start transcribing,
you have to unravel that part,
those complex structures that
are tightly wrapped up.
You've got make the
double-stranded DNA accessible,
otherwise you can't
break into it.
So there are two things
that also contribute
to allowing transcription, and
those occur both at the DNA
level, and the histone level.
And I'm going to talk about the
histone level changes first.
I want you to recall that
histones are proteins that
have a lot of positive charge,
by virtue of the fact that they
include two of the positively
charged amino acids, arginine
and lysine.
And if you're curious
about those structures,
you can go look back at the
table of the amino acids
and see that those guys are
always positively charged.
The reason we use histones as
the core of the nucleus home
structure, is they're
very positively charged,
and they neutralize the
dense negative charge
of the nucleic acid.
Otherwise we couldn't pack
it up as tightly as we do.
So changes that occur
at the histone level,
and their remodeling
of the chromatin
in order to promote
transcription
is modification oftentimes
to neutralize those charges.
So the one most obvious one
I'll show you, and then there
are others where you
add methyl groups that
dampen down the charge.
But I'm just going to show
you the very obvious one.
So let's just look at
lysine in a protein.
That looks like this.
That is a terrible drawing.
It has a positive
charge for bonds
to nitrogen. In order to
neutralize that charge,
there are enzymes that
acylate, or transfer
an acyl group to turn this
positively charged amine
into a neutral amide.
Let me draw that side
chain, because I think
it makes much more
sense to understand it,
this particular thing from
a chemical perspective.
So we still have the n but
it is now part of an amide.
So the charge has been
neutralized on the nitrogen.
If the charge is neutralized on
the positively charged residues
in the histones, the
DNA will be encouraged
to unravel from those.
It makes good chemical
sense that that's a good way
to start on packaging DNA.
The other modification
occurs at the DNA level
and it's methylation
of cytosine.
A little harder to explain
from a chemical sense,
but up there in the
corner of this slide
I've shown you the pictures.
So methylation on cytosine
would look like this.
This encourages stabilization
of the chromatin.
So what would that do
to transcription if I've
stabilized the chromatin?
It represses it.
It turns it down.
So these are pairs of changes
that act in opposite direction.
So we'd go down-regulate
transcription.
OK, so DNA methylation
causes the chromatin
to be a bit more
compact, more stable.
It's much harder
to unravel the DNA.
It's obviously then harder
to start transcription.
In contrast, modification
of the histone proteins
to neutralize their charges
destabilizes and up-regulates
transcription,
because it's allowing
us to open up the
nucleosomes in order
to make the DNA available.
Does that all make sense?
So we have two counter-balances
that play in each direction.
OK?
All right, so that's
chromatic remodeling.
The next two transformations
I'll show you
may certainly look
fairly complicated.
But I'm going to
describe them to you,
and show you what
the changes are,
and how they would contribute
to stabilizing the transcript
and finishing the
transcript up, to make
it ready to leave the
nucleus, to go out
to the cytoplasm, where the
machinery to translate proteins
is.
Because you want to
remember the ribosomes
that we're going to use on
Friday aren't in the nucleus.
They're in the cytoplasm.
So there is a variety of events.
There is what's known
as 5 prime capping.
So that is going to be a change.
Let's just say this goes down.
This is the base.
Remember 1, 2, 3 prime,
4 prime, 5 prime.
It's something that's happening
to this end of the messenger
RNA that stabilizes it.
So 5 prime capping is
important for one end.
And then at the other end
there is polyadenylation
of the 3 prime end.
OK, so let's just look
at these one at a time.
And let me convince
you that they
are important changes in the
transcript that will preserve
its identity, and in fact,
give it a little bit more
information.
Because indeed, the 5 prime
capping modification actually
is a signal later on, when the
transcript leaves the nucleus
for protein translation.
But in general, both
of these changes
mechanically protect the
ends of the part of the gene
that you're going to
want to translate.
They basically leave
that piece of gene
in the middle, where it's
not going to be nibbled up,
it's not going to be degraded.
Because the biggest
threat to the messenger
RNA are things known
as exonucleases.
Exonucleases chew down nucleic
acids from the two ends.
All right.
So let's look
first, and it's kind
of wild and crazy chemistry,
at the 5 prime capping.
And then we'll
discuss the other two.
And then I will finish
these types of changes
with splicing, which is really
cool and extremely important.
But the transcript,
the pre-messenger RNA
has to go through
all of these steps
before it's ready
for nuclear export.
So in 5 prime capping,
you have this strand
of pre-messenger RNA.
Everything looks pretty happy.
It's all in one piece.
But the first thing that
happens is three phosphates
are added to that
5 prime OH group.
So that's the start
of this process.
And this process
actually happens
while you're still transcribing
the double-stranded DNA.
It's actually already going on.
As soon as that component
of the newly transcribed
pre-messenger RNA
is made, things
start happening at the 5
prime end to protect it.
At that stage, then once
those three phosphates
are put on there, and
nucleobase is added backwards.
So there's a couple
of functions.
This all looks pretty strange.
The rest of this still
looks quite good.
It looks fairly intact.
But then the next
thing that happens
is that the guanine
that's here is--
you do not have to remember this
stuff, I couldn't remember it.
I just want to show you
how weird and different
the 5 prime end looks.
It doesn't look like
a strand of RNA.
So the guanine is methylated.
And then a couple
of the riboses,
those sugars that have
an OH usually at 2 prime,
get methylated.
So we've created this entire
thing at the 5 prime end,
known as the 5 prime
cap that looks nothing
like regular messenger RNA.
And that protects that
end of the messenger,
and makes it safe from
a variety of insults.
So let's take a look.
Why does it happen?
So the first thing is it
stops nuclease activity.
Because the nuclease
could look at it, and go,
I don't recognize any
of this happy mess.
I'm not going to chop
down this component.
It's too foreign to me.
So that's the primary thing.
But then it's actually quite
important for regulation
of when that messenger
needs to leave the nucleus.
There are proteins
involved in helping export
the messenger RNA, when
it's ready from the nucleus.
So it's an important signal
or recognition element.
It marks this thing
as a messenger RNA
that's going to be
important in translation.
It gives it an identity.
And then finally, it can
actually in the next step
promote translation.
So all of these
things are useful.
So we do a number of these
unusual transformations,
but they all have a
reason, and they all
carried out in the
nucleus purposed
to protect the 5 prime
cap of the messenger,
and actually make it
ready for its next tasks.
All right?
The next thing that
happens is what's
known as polyadenylation.
So here's it.
This would be the 5 prime cap.
In the middle would be
your gene that you're
going to transcribe.
But at the other end there is
an enzyme that puts on a lot
of adenine nucleotides, and
basically adds to the other end
a lot of A's.
And when I say a lot,
it can be hundreds.
And it just promiscuously
keeps on adenylating.
And now what's this bit for?
Once again, it protects
from exonuclease activity
from the other
end of the strand.
Because if you have
exonuclease activity,
you might start munching
away at these As.
But these aren't the important
parts of the messenger, right?
These are just add-ons.
It's kind of a buffer.
It's like something to
do while you're waiting.
Oh, I'm going to
chew up some As.
But you're not messing
up the messenger RNA
that you need at the end.
So it's adding
some dummy sequence
that will be handy there.
It contributes to stability.
The tail is shortened over
time, but it's non-coding,
so that's OK.
And actually though, when
the tail is short enough,
the polyadenine tail kind
of acts as a bit of a timer.
Because once the
tail gets short,
you start chewing
into the transcript,
and you basically end up with a
degradation of the transcript.
But it gives you time in
the cytoplasm for the gene
to be translated into protein.
Does that all make sense?
So it's basically like an egg
timer, just watching, watching;
back, back, back.
OK, this transcript has
been out here long enough.
We've made all the
protein we need.
Now we're going to chew
up the coding part.
And then finally it's
actually a good marker
again for leaving the nucleus.
And then finally it's kind of
a cool tool for technology,
because there's lots of interest
in characterizing what's
known as the transcriptome.
OK, it's all well and good
to characterize a genome.
But it's a lot of work,
3.2 billion base pairs.
And only a part of
it, a tiny part of it,
are parts of the genes
that encode the proteins.
So what you'd
really want to know,
if you want to
analyze the genes that
are going to become the proteins
and maybe look for defects,
is look at the things that
are going to be transcribed.
So you can use the
fact that there
is this poly-A tail on
the transcripts that
are going to leave the
nucleus with something that
will pull them out of the mix.
What would I use?
Let's say I've got a
resin bead, polystyrene
or some favorable polymer.
And I can attach covalently
nucleic acids to that bead.
What would I add there
to fish this lot out?
Yeah, up here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
Yeah, a lot of Ts.
So I'm going to make this.
I'm going to put on a bunch of
Ts, and I can do this a lot.
This is done very,
very commonly.
And then I'm just
going to fish out
everything that is part of the
transcriptome, not the genome.
So I've got a much smaller
job then to find out errors
in the genes that
encode the proteins,
than if I was going to start
with the entire genome.
So pretty cool tool,
and later on we're
going to see how
this can be used.
It's actually used in concert
with an interesting enzyme
that comes from viruses
called reverse transcriptase.
But that's a story
for a later day.
But it is a cool story.
Now the last thing that
we do in the nucleus
is arguably the most important.
And that is splicing.
OK, all right.
Once again, this is a picture
with a lot of moving parts.
But I want to convey to
you the point of splicing,
as opposed to you knowing
all the little details.
It was noticed for a long
time that the messenger didn't
always correspond to
the original transcript.
And this is the case
eukaryotes, not in bacteria.
But that there was quite
a lot of processing
done, not just to cap the
ends, but by cutting out
chunks of the transcript,
so removal of segments
of the transcript.
And a lot of the
seminal work was
done by Phillip Sharp, who
is a member of our faculty
in the Biology Department.
So we're very proud of this.
This was actually the topic
of a Nobel Prize in the '90s.
And so what was noticed is that
if you had a gene, and let's
just put it here,
5 prime to 3 prime.
And I'm going to name these.
And then I'll explain
to you what they are.
These would be called exons.
These would be called intros.
And this is another exon.
Outside, inside; that's
the way to remember them.
And what happens in
splicing is that the introns
are chopped out.
OK, so your gene
then ends up being,
if this is exon
1 and exon 2, not
represented by
this entire thing,
but eliminating that
middle component.
And remember all the time
we have the cap at 5,
we have the poly-A tail ad
infinitum, the 3 prime end.
So we've just
changed the middle.
And it was recognized through
bioinformatics analysis that
basically noticed the
pieces that was chopped out
and the pieces that
ended up being joined.
And protein splicing
occurs as a sequence
of events that ends you up
with the protein being spliced
together through a
series of rearrangements
that occur on the structure
of the messenger RNA.
So there is an
internal rearrangement.
A new phosphate is made.
And then there's
another rearrangement,
where there's a new
bond made between one
end of the pre-messenger
RNA, and the other end
of the pre-messenger
RNA, to give you
the exon rejoined, ready
to be read in translation.
Now why is this so important?
So I want to go here
to a few numbers
that I think are
very pertinent, which
I had to drill my
colleagues for,
because I didn't
know all the numbers.
So when the genome
was sequenced,
we were a bit stunned,
because the number
of coding things
that are genes that
are going to be
turned into proteins
was much smaller
than we anticipated.
For man, it's currently
at about 20,000 genes.
That's 20,000 mature transcripts
that could make proteins.
Fly?
Not much smaller, arguably
they're pretty smart, 16,000.
Yeast 6,000, a
bacteria at 4,000.
There doesn't seem to be
enough of a difference.
But a huge amount
of diversity is
introduced into the transcripts
by different splicing events.
Because if you make
one transcript,
that would count as one gene.
But if there is a lot of
opportunities for difference
splicing activity,
you can piece together
new transcripts that will
encode proteins differently.
And I think this next
slide will show you
an example of a transcript that
has several different introns
and exons.
So you can see here
across, there's
a blue, green, red, another
blue, and an orange exon.
But depending on which
pieces are spliced out,
we'll have different
proteins end up.
So it could be a
way, for example,
to think of a practical use, to
have a protein that is either
secreted as a soluble
protein, or left
in the membrane with a
membrane association domain,
or left in the cytoplasm because
it has no way to be secreted.
So it could be a way to
make three proteins that
are in completely
different places of a cell,
or have different functions.
It's also very
important in tissues,
because we splice proteins
differently in muscle,
or liver, or heart to
achieve different outcomes
in the proteins that we make.
So basically, it's a
source of huge diversity,
and it gives us the
genetic diversity
that means this 20,000 can
be a much bigger number.
And then with the
post-translational
modifications I talk about
when we come back later on,
you'll see we've got lots of
ways to diversify that 20,000.
That mean these aren't
literal numbers.
They're quite varied.
But what you want to remember
is E. coli doesn't do splicing.
There's no opportunity there.
It's much more limited
in yeast, so is
the post-translational
modification.
So these numbers settle
out quite differently
from what they look
like by looking directly
at those numbers.
And I wanted to
give you an example.
You don't have this
in your slides,
but I was thinking
about it the other day.
A colleague of mine, Professor
Pentelute in chemistry,
works on trying
to reprogram genes
to overcome a disease known as
Duchenne muscular dystrophy.
It's another genetic disorder.
It's X-linked.
So it's much more serious
in males than in females.
Because if you only have
one bad copy of the gene,
you can do OK with this disease.
Whereas in the male,
you'd only have
the component of the gene
that's on the X chromosome.
And it's a defect in RNA
splicing, so directly there.
So this is a biopsy
of muscle where
red would be good muscle
cells, whereas the white would
be fat cells.
And they actually weaken
the integrity of the muscle,
because the muscle
doesn't develop
to have all the well-defined
muscle cells that
are important for
muscle tensile strength,
and contractility, and
everything else that muscles
do.
And it's all related to a
protein known as dystrophin,
which is a huge protein.
And it's a critical
structural protein
that's important to maintain
the cellular membranes
within the muscle cells.
So if dystrophin is no good,
the cell membrane integrity
is no good.
And you just end up
with losing the muscle
cells, a cost of replacing them
with fat cells in the muscle.
And here's a really
amazing number.
The gene that encodes
dystrophin has 79 exons.
So you can picture the
opportunities for things
to go wrong, and it's
actually a defect in the place
where the splicing happens.
So a splicing event
cannot happen.
And so the protein at the
end of the day is not good.
So there's a lot of
efforts going on,
antisense efforts, and even
other gene therapy efforts,
and also nowadays there's
obviously a large focus
on CRISPR-based gene editing.
But remember this is
a serious debilitating
disease of all muscle tissue.
It starts to be noticed when
the babies are toddlers,
because that's really
when they start
to engage muscle strength.
So around the age of four
it's actually noticed.
And then the life
expectancy is in the 30
to 40-years-old range.
But it's also a
terrible lifestyle,
because the lungs don't work.
So many things rely
on muscle strength.
OK, good.
All right, so I believe
that's the end of that.
But I want to give you an
introduction to translation,
so you'll see what we
have in store for Friday.
And just get you
back to this picture,
we've done everything we need.
We've done all the processing.
We're here, and then
the mature messenger RNA
can finally leave the nucleus
to be ready for translation.
And the cap-- there
is a complex that
binds the 5 prime
cap that's tasked
with helping export
that transcript
through the nuclear pore, which
is a fairly large opening,
outside into the cytoplasm.
And I want to show
you one other thing
and I hope I can
get this reliably,
because with this I'm
going to actually show you
some of the moving parts.
There's a little
thing on the sidebar
now, called a short translation.
And so what you're seeing
here, the black line
is the messenger RNA.
OK, so that's the thing
that's finally out
there in the cytoplasm ready.
The pale green and yellow
are the two components
of the ribosome, which is
a soluble organelle that
assembles on the double-stranded
DNA based on a few cues.
The dark blue components
are transfer RNAs
that bring in new amino acids.
And what you see
threading out here
is a new protein strand
that is being translated.
This particular translation is
to make a protein that becomes
membrane bound and secreted.
So I'm not going to
go further than that.
But there's a lot of
those light blue proteins
that are actually helping
escort the transfer
RNAs to where they're needed to
continue building the proteins.
So we've seen the messenger.
We'll learn more
about the ribosome,
and will learn about
the transfer RNAs.
And you can also watch this
to your heart's content.
I just find it just a
useful simple cartoon
that tells us a lot.
So what I really want
to encourage you to do
is read this section 14.5,
because the next parts will
make a great deal more sense.
So what I want to do
though now is first of all,
start with describing the
players in translation,
and just the way we
did for replication,
we're going to systematically
ascribe the importance
to each of these players.
So what you see, there
are molecular players
and there are key steps.
So the molecular
players are shown here.
So far, we've focused very
strongly on the messenger RNA.
You know all about that.
You know where it's from.
You know it's stable in
the cytoplasm for a while.
You know it's got signals
that tell the complexes where
to go down.
Then we need transfer
RNAs and amino acids,
and we need the ribosomes.
And ribosomes are made of
a composite of nucleic acid
and protein wrapped together.
There's quite a big
difference in prokaryotes
and eukaryotic
ribosomes, and I'll
mention that when we get to it.
But I want to focus for a
few moments, first of all,
on the landmarks that got us to
finally in 2009 the structure
of the ribosome.
It's a cool development
for everyone.
But also where we came
from in the '60s, when
Crick and Brenner finally
cracked the genetic code,
and found out that three
bases on that messenger
RNA will encode
each new amino acid
that gets put into
your protein sequence.
So I want to introduce you
to the transfer RNAs that
are really the most
important element
to start thinking about.
And you can call these
guys the decoders,
because what the
transfer RNA does
is it can carry an amino acid
on one end of its nucleic acid.
But on one of the other
loops within the transfer
RNA is what's known
as an anticodon that
recognizes a codon
in the messenger RNA,
and basically prescribes
what amino acids get put in.
So it was always a wonder how
you went from the nucleic acid
world to the protein world.
The answer is you
use a nucleic acid
that you can load
with an amino acid,
but it can also recognize
the messenger RNA that codes
for the protein sequence.
And that's why I like to
think of them as decoders.
But what this picture
of the RNA shows you,
is the beautiful
structure of RNA,
where at one end is where an
amino acid would be attached.
There's this cool kind
of cloverleaf structure.
And then at the other
end is the anticodon loop
that will actually recognize
your messenger RNA.
So I'm going to stop now.
But I really want to
encourage you, just skim
through that small section.
It'll make a lot
more sense on Friday.
I've been waiting to talk to
you about protein translation
since we started this class.
But it'll make a lot more sense.
And there's some super cool
initiatives in chemical biology
now, where people have been
able to completely hijack
protein translation,
and not put in just
20 regular boring amino
acids, but actually
put in all kinds of
other amino acids.
So we understand the system
well enough to manipulate it.
And this really hearkens
to the Feynman quotes,
"If you can build it,
you can understand it."
That's the level to which
we understand translation
nowadays.
That's it for today.